i've not
listened to this let's listen to it
together
and and see what it what it's about
i'm sick and [ __ ] tired and listen to
your [ __ ]
about unhinged trump supporters and this
and that
make yourself full of [ __ ] i i got
my hat's off to you you can't you you
you
can't withstand it david yeah my
information [ __ ]
[Music]
[ __ ] your cappuccino
[ __ ] your cappuccino
[Music]
[ __ ] your cappuccino
[ __ ] your cappuccinos
[Music]
[ __ ] your cappuccino
ladies and gentlemen
leaders and fighters for freedom and
liberty and the american dream
the best is yet to come
stand back and stand by
[Music]
let's please continue on person woman
man camera tv all the networks
all the networks person woman
man camera tv
[Music]
because i'm cognitively therefore
what is going on here we won't talk
about toilets
it's a very unpleasant story you know
they call them dumps big massive dumps
if my grandmother had wheels instead of
legs
oranges oranges she would be a bicycle
god bless the united church thank you
very much
if there is anything that needs to be uh
satirized and remixed
it is trump talking about massive dumps
and by the way extra points if you can
sample
trump saying massive dumps and me
talking about it in a song
please do it
[Music]
donald trump insisted multiple times
that it was massive dumps that led him
to lose the election
which is just
[Music]
stumps dumps dumps
dumps dumps what is going on here
what is going what is going on here
it's just beyond parody a massive all
right everybody
let's get started i can't waste any more
time we've been away
for about 10 days i've been on vacation
i had a deep
nose schwab and i tell the story
on today's bonus show so really really
big bonus show today i will talk about
actually
a lot of different schwabbings
shockingly took place
around our vacation so really really
exciting bonus show but we are back
we are back i am tan yeah that's not do
not adjust your tv
my forehead is extremely tan
and i didn't even have time to shave
it's all crazy
wow look at that look at that
okay so we are back we've got a gensake
press briefing coming up in a little bit
i did manage to avoid covid during the
trip i
i am fully vaccinated the vaccines are
very effective
but i also didn't do anything stupid i
was tested on the way out i was tested
on the way in
the test scores were i mean no you would
have thought i
bought my way into these test scores
like lori laughlin
right because that that's how good
doctors said we've never seen
anyone do with a covid test what you
were able to do
uh in aruba so really really crazy stuff
all right i have unban requests
i have videos i have clips i have
uh the latest cancellation where people
are saying cancel me
i'll tell you why and a hundred people
did
uh but first let me make sure i'm caught
up on thanking everybody who signed up
because we are in the toilet with subs
excuse me let's see thanks to hard lined
for the six months
this is blood for the gift astro lycos
gifting five putting us at seven
this is blood with another gift putting
us at eight louis curtain is nine
tegan marie is ten life as good as
eleven
dirt nap is twelve
is that it ky dizzle is thirteen
nor m northrup is 14 chaotic stasis is
15
this is blood is 16.
um and then oh noog
wrongler signed up a couple days ago
again but i'm going to count it because
new grongler actually put together a
really nice
this is an effort post okay this is from
the david pakman show
subreddit check this out analysis of
march 22. this is really high quality
content okay
if you need a if you need a role model
in terms of
content generation new grangler is the
person to follow
a little board with no show this week so
i analyzed this month calls
four weeks of friday calls and one
session of stream
calls a full visual analysis
of the phone calls including new york
illinois florida being the most
represented
states and the uk being the most
represented
foreign country interesting tidbits
11 of 33 calls were international
each session had at least two
international callers four of them on
the third week caveat
the spain caller in week three actually
lived in nebraska
the new delhi caller from week two did
not sound like they were from new delhi
that's pretty aggressive but i still
i still appreciate the analysis every
session
took eight calls with the exception of
week four which took nine
week two was the only week where there
were no dropped calls
here is a word cloud of topics brought
up by callers
uh the right covid local issue
seemed to be big topics for callers this
is really good good material
notable descriptions of disruptions
these are my quotes
sounds like you are underground i
remember that one
did you just pop a soda open yeah there
was like a
a caller where it sounded like that kids
in the background yep i remember that
call as well
anything in the data you find
interesting that is a really
strong analysis that isn't what i call
an effort post really really well done
stuff
data data always pro data
okay so thank you to noog wrangler
for that one also thank you to dollar
batteries
and grungy dan for the twitch subs as
well as
sc cowell that is
three putting us at 20 already
and then very very special also want to
say
thanks to nathan quimby for subscribing
on my website
joinpakman.com with the coupon code
better21 that is
number 21 today thank you very very much
super chats oh my god that is
humiliating
no super chats yet that's horrible
but thanks to milo wilde for the 10
gifted subs putting us at 31 okay
here was an attempted cancellation that
i suffered now
over the break i was really iffy as to
whether i should post
any pictures from my vacation why there
are so many people right now
that are what whoa the gavel just uh i'm
getting ahead of myself with the gavel
i was just worried people would be very
judgey you know the cdc said it's
you can travel if vaccinated just follow
the rules of the place you're going to
and be safe which is what i did
i did decide about halfway through my
trip
to post a picture of me on the beach
this is on my instagram as you may see
legendary child actor casey simpson
called it legend
you know not that everybody here cares
what a 16 year old actor believes
but legendary child actor casey simpson
calling it
legend um i posted this i didn't even
say where i was other than saying i'm
not in florida
100 people unfollowed me now if you go
back i looked at my social blade
for instagram if you go back to the
beginning of my instagram account
i've never lost followers i post a
picture of myself traveling during a
time where some people are angry
about anybody who's vaccinated and
traveling lost 100 followers
whatever these are not people that that
those folks are
aren't my core audience by definition
okay
i did it i i went
a hundred people said unfollow because i
did it
and to them we wish them uh we wish them
good luck and good night all right so
there is that you can follow me on
instagram at david.pakman
we already went over this we went over
this we went over this
um oh okay here's a user who printed out
one of my instagram
pictures holding my tomato harvest
looks like somebody in the uk or maybe
you know another country where they have
right-hand drive
they printed it and now they made an air
freshener
with a picture of me holding tomatoes
now what would be amazing is
if the air freshener is tomato scented
that would be really really powerful
this is user
olinderm on
the subreddit really really clever
alright i really like that
i wasn't in florida guys i wasn't in
florida for people continuing to say i
was in florida i did not go to florida
um big thank you to rhapsody's
on graz for the 13-month subscription
also thanks to anonymous gifter for the
gift
kathy sandoval for the sub that's three
putting us at 34. i am counting patreon
yeah if people i
i will count patreon today because uh
we're just counting it
patreon counts let's look at some super
chats welcome back
missed you thank you for the sauce
recommendation carnitas poutine was
great
did you see the public garden lagoon is
drained no i don't know
at this point i'm so out of touch with
what's going on back in boston i don't
know
chakaseki says welcome back hope you had
a restorative vacation
germaine says got my first dose of
moderna
can we pass infrastructure under
reconciliation yes i believe that we can
alex says hope you had a good vacation
got my second pappizer dose
in michigan why our case is skyrocketing
um
cases are skyrocketing because a b117 is
dominating michigan
and vaccination hasn't happened fast
enough but the good news
is cases are starting to go back down
i don't some people are talking about a
fourth wave
of course wave one two and three
some people said this is the start of
wave four i don't think so i think in
the next six weeks we are going to
outrun
the variants the vaccines work on the
variance
deaths continue to decline as you can
see here death's never
leveled out other than like a five-day
leveling
uh i think we're going to be fine we
probably will need boosters in about
nine months
but i think we are going to be fine and
for me look at these
look at these massive dumps of vaccines
for a 3.975 basically 4 million
on april 2nd almost 4.1 million on april
3rd
3.3 3.3 is now like a bad day okay
we are vaccinating one percent of the
population a day
this is unbelievable stuff unbelievable
stuff all right so everybody just keep
doing what what we've been doing
if you've been doing the right things
thanks to nancy kendall nancy
coming in out of nowhere at
joinpacman.com with a new membership
using the coupon code better21 nancy i
cannot
thank you enough also thanks to a danish
joint fino team
poop colon that's a proctologist by the
way
and apollotron for the twitch subs
putting us at 39.
um what else do we have here fully
vaccinated already having withdrawals
that's my air freshener shout out to
issy for the gift
beautiful welcome back hope you had a
good vacation massachusetts opening to
adults on april 16th getting the jnj
saturday love to hear it mikey
absolutely love to hear it um
okay let's adjudicate some
unban requests if i may on twitch when
people get banned they have the
ability to appeal the ban we have a
gavel to adjudicate these unban requests
i have two the first one is
a user named commander james leahy
who showed up and said dems shill for
corporate media
um they were not banned for that
then they came back and attacked someone
by saying
get out of your commie cuck bubble
then they showed up and said about joe
biden
this isn't a real person suggesting i
guess that it's like cgi
they were banned their unban request
is f you you shill
that is denied and confirmed permaban
another user named i'm faint
rogue showed up i guess on the last
stream
and said lmao
biden doesn't know where he is
he's losing it he's your president
how sad to watch him struggle because
he's senile we told you lmao
lmao what a joke someone needs to get
him
okay at someone needs to get him it went
over
trolling into threats and they were
banned
their unbanned request is what a joke
you call this a strong leader when he
loses his place stumbles over words
can't remember where he is and how sad
this
is and when someone points out you
banned them
seems and um but what you great a comedy
show
effort that is
aside from the unintelligible unban
request
it is denied and confirmed that is a
perma-ban
all right so a lot of housekeeping today
because we've been away caught up
on unbanned requests so that is that
david i saw an article saying the
vaccines only last in your system for
three months i saw that in a washington
post article
uh no what we know so far is that there
is no reduction in immunity
six months in the reason why it's six
months is because that's how long it's
been tracked
the the most likely situation is that
the vaccines are effective for years
against
the base variance if the predominant
variant
is different six or eight months from
now we would probably
need boosters i don't know the article
you're referring to
that's not uh yeah that that's
not true based on everything i've seen
crazy nate says hey david it's me nathan
quimby i was glad to sub to your website
because since last year i was shown your
content i know
way more than ever before thank you
nathan
jd straightshot says some people are
saying gates was about to release the
republican healthcare plan
that's why the deep state is
investigating him yeah well well done
nicely done okay
um a couple of other things here here's
another satire
this is a satire of me by
reddit user franchenol satirizing a
an eggman phone call let's listen we
have a voicemail number
that number is 219 to david p
listen to this call from the eggman
dave so confused about something i keep
hearing you talk about milk toast
yes why do you use that word to talk
about trump shalom brother
okay not sure if the egg man
uh is kidding but
when i refer to donald trump's answers
to questions as milk toast
i am calling those answers lazy
tepid and ineffectual right
we have a fantastic bonus show
for you today there it is oh okay oh
hold on let's see
producer pat and i will be covering the
latest drama with
rudy giuliani right and also if you'd
like to see me be
absolutely smothered by a large animal
follow me on my instagram so that's
basically
perfect here is another one uh
this is i guess a deep fake of me saying
something let me see what this is
we got a number one victory royale yeah
fortnight we bout to get down
10 kills on the board right now just
wiped out tomato town
my friend just got down i revived him
now we're heading southbound
now we're in the pleasant park streets
look at the map go to the market
okay so that's that's pretty nicely done
that's good
um okay let's see what else we've got
keep up the awesome content
great work david thank you did you watch
the q documentary on hbo max
no joe says welcome back my wife and i
are traversing the tesla charging
network to the rockies in summer for our
first vacation since 2019 fully vaxxed
nice
i just got my first tesla referral i got
a referral
so i will get 1 000 free supercharger
miles which is exciting
i'm 18 and getting my first dose in two
days here in south carolina the vaccine
is open to everyone
is it smart to open to everyone not just
at risk we are very close to when the
issue is not going to be supply
it'll be limited by other factors so i
think if not now we're close to being
ready to open to everybody
yes very very close
uh okay oh
okay you know since we have time let's
do this this is really good
the next uh video edit contest
is doing david pakman show versions of
this
infamous viral video
okay i have four now here's the thing i
have ten memberships to give away
okay i've only received four videos yet
so so far
like everybody gets one you should
hopefully be inspired by this and send
one in
okay let's look at here's the first
submission from i believe this is from
nick
here we go
[Applause]
guess what i got a fever
and the only prescription is more
cowbell
it was a perfect storm really
welcome to san francisco mr buckowski
[Music]
oh these people don't know what the hell
they're doing
let me recover my ears for one second
all right so that is submission number
one
here is submission number two there is a
literal
crime rate
[Music]
people that support trump know what a
story is called
i don't actually really get this one
like it has nothing to do with the david
pakman show except for i guess this last
moment hi enjoy yourself
that's not bad that's not bad explosion
caused by the adjudicator
uh that's number two here is the second
one
this one people may like this one
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign
oh this is a nice touch the hair product
i mentioned i use is actually the bongo
that's genius actually
okay so that's submission number three
and then here is submission number four
this one's really aggressive okay
everybody careful
[Music]
like
[Music]
okay so those are the four submissions
so far
remember this is the original
protection that's number one with vets
it even prevents the infection that
causes lyme disease oh my god
okay that's coming from somewhere else
anyway still plenty of time to get yours
submitted okay some of them are more
aggressive than others i invite you to
submit yours
today very very exciting i also want to
say thank you to
juan wick for subscribing via twitch
your new subscriber number
40 today 40 today and
um what is the coupon code the coupon
codes right there better 21.
now i'm going to be honest with you guys
like none of our coupon codes ever
expire
we kind of we stopped promoting them but
like they still work
so if you wanted you could still use the
immoral coupon code on my website
immoral21 you could do it you could do
it i'm not saying go and do it but i am
saying
if you did it would work and i would
still thank you i know it's
i don't even know that it's legal uh the
legal eagle you know actually you know
what would be a great segment
i need to have the legal eagle do an
assessment
of our discount codes to actually test
them
both for pres precedent and
constitutionality
that would be a segment to go to at some
point all right
let's look at some other super chats
coming in
what new bombshells should we expect
from gates photos of him in a toga with
a beer funnel guiding young women to his
house
office in dc that wouldn't surprise me
honestly
it wouldn't surprise me wondering what
grade you'd give biden two-thirds of the
way through the first
100 you know i think a grade is too
simplistic
but i think that he's done he's gotten a
lot of great things done
and is not really cow towing to
republicans which i like
but we'll have a more detailed grading
soon
dave any news on the job posting can you
shout out a brother channel long
time coming for you all your diy law
needs
lol dp2024 so i announced the new job
posting um some weeks ago
we got about 350 initial submissions
probably about 50 of the 350 didn't meet
the basic requirements
like they didn't even apply the way i
said to apply
or they don't they don't live in the
united states it does have to be an
american citizen
that we hire um so that narrowed it from
350 to 300
i then followed up up with the 300
with some additional information about
the position that probably winnowed it
down to about
250 after the 250
we went to a sort of skills test
mimicking some of the tasks that will be
part of the job
and i only got about 80 back
so of the 250 that we sent the skills
test to
only 80 responded and the deadline for
that is now passed
so a lot of people clearly self i guess
a lot of people thought they would be a
good fit but then when they actually saw
the skills test
they bailed so now we have i haven't
been looking at this during our vacation
but now i have about 80 skills tests to
go through
um the next step will be
the the top skills tests will be
called in for an interview and we will
go from there
so that's where things stand so the 350
have been winnowed
down to about 80. i took a look at the
skills tests
some are not going to be up to par so i
believe that
um i believe that the 80
will probably be 50 that are serious
contenders
maybe even 40. i looked at a few and it
was not
not so good so that's the process right
now we're down to about 80.
yeah and i see people saying they didn't
want to do free work for you
listen guys um you know i'm not asking
people to do hours of work here or to
like
do coding work that we need done you
know i've heard of
software companies actually getting
applicants to do coding work
these are very minimal tasks that will
very quickly separate the wheat from the
chaff
and uh if you know if people don't want
to spend 20 to 30 minutes doing them
that's totally fine you know we had
we still got 80 people that did want to
do it we only are hiring one
so it's perfectly everything's all good
everything's all good okay other super
chats coming in
hey david canada here got my first shot
astrazeneca
how close to herd immunity do we need to
be up here for you to come and visit can
you imagine
it's for me it's not about herd immunity
the cdc has said
vaccinated people can travel i just
don't think we're allowed
to go to canada i don't think americans
are allowed to go right now
paper paper you i
canada we are still getting vaccine to
people 60 and older
wish i was in your group you cut the ad
off how do i prevent lyme disease
avoid getting uh bit by a tick how do we
combat
rising authoritarianism in in
us or in the us if in us i
i don't know that's really a very
personal question
if you mean in the u.s i have a number
of uh clips about that
which you can find on my youtube channel
nico james says david what are your
thoughts on having socially conservative
democrats who are economically more
liberal in states like alabama and
mississippi
do do you mean having them as voters or
having them as elected officials
it's sort of a joke if it's the latter
it's really a joe mansion question
in the sense that you know bernie
wouldn't win in west virginia
so it's more realistic to think it's
going to be mansion or potentially a
republican
but i may be misunderstanding the
question thanks to
jayton deway for the six months
subscribed on twitch
very much appreciate that does a
person's
political views come into play when you
hire
uh i mean listen uh i'm not aware of any
right wingers that have applied
i don't know why a right winger would
want to work on the show
gallis gallagher says how was the david
pakman show vacation it was
excellent today's bonus show i go into
detail
about my flights my uh
nasal deep nasal swab about
embarrassing americans at airports
around the world
i tell the full story on today's bonus
show
so my recommendation would be listen to
the bonus show
which you can access by signing
up sorry i froze at
joinpackman.com it will be live in about
45 minutes so that's all
all happening soon all right so we
looked at these videos already
we can close this out and this
all right we are standing by here for
gen
saki i see people um
on both youtube and twitch chatting
about sort of like
all the normal things like david you're
muted
the audio and video is unsynced the
stream is repeating itself
all of this stuff just refresh just
refresh
99 of your problems will go away if you
refresh
no no sweat welcome back david i'm a 60
year old
lyme's disease long-hauler and was so
grateful to receive
the jnj vaccine on saturday that's great
news julie
great news jody says hiya david can we
say
dave sure do y'all need any data
analysts aka
data males i i don't know
hi david love your show i got my second
vaccine on friday how would you say
we're doing on the vaccine rollout we
are doing well
i mean listen i would love to be doing
better but we are now
giving a dose to one percent of the
population
every day look at that 3.08 million
doses per day
that is that's like one percent now it's
not
a full vaccination because many of those
are two dose
but one percent of the population is
getting
a vaccine or an
vaccine i don't even care grammatically
whatever
every single day those are really good
numbers
and i am confident we will see probably
in the next six weeks we are going to
see
a big downward spiral in case numbers
case numbers
an axine yeah i like that too that's not
bad
that's not bad okay we are standing by
for jensaki there's also the derrick
chauvin trial currently in a break we
may
dip in and out of that as well but we
are currently standing by
for the press briefing about to begin
we will see if there are questions nasty
or otherwise
yeah cases are going to go very positive
from the standpoint of negative they are
going to
skyrocket in the down sense
right you guys remember that president
who used to say stuff like that
i want to say a huge thank you to
michael
rabazza for signing up at
joinedpakman.com
you are new member number 42 today
multiple coupon codes available for
people today
um did i ever replace my laptop i didn't
i didn't i didn't find something
suitable i got about a hundred emails
about it 90
didn't even understand i wanted a laptop
90 of the emails were about desktop
computers
the other 10 had some ideas but nothing
super definitive
that i moved on i want to say thanks to
nikki 206
who is now 16 months subscribed via
twitch prime
really appreciate that crazy nate says
can you check out my super chat
as far as i know i did yeah i i did
i did i already read it dealt with it
earlier nathan thank you
do you think we will have possible
vaccine eligibility for kids 15 and
under this year
i think that there will be at least one
vaccine
for 12 to 16 this year i do think so
just looking at looking at the
scholarship on it following uh people
like eric dr
eric topple and others on on twitter
i believe that we will get a 12 to 16
vaccine eua
emergency use authorization this year
um and i'm i'm relatively confident
about it quite frankly
david you're beating both majority
report and tyt and twitch viewers
right now i have 700 viewers on twitch
that can't possibly be true
let's see i didn't even know that they
were live
uh majority report 5 47
oh it's easter right is today a holiday
i know i thought easter was sunday but i
guess today is a holiday somewhere
here we go okay
all right just one update for all of you
at the top um
president is always is obviously quite
focused on the american jobs plan that
he just announced
last week as you all know he's already
had two bipartisan congressional
meetings on infrastructure in the oval
office and he plans to continue speaking
with leaders
from both sides of the aisle to get
their input either on the phone this
week or when they return he looks
forward to welcoming
members to the oval office right again
uh
and this work is being supported of
course by the jobs cabinet many of you
may have seen
members of the jobs cabinet out over the
weekend speaking uh
on your airwaves directly to the
american people
and the jobs cabinet members have also
been active and engaging with members of
congress
on both sides of the aisle and they will
continue to play that role
over the course of the coming weeks and
months so jobs cabinet members to date
have made 56
calls to the 28 democrats and 28
republicans
who are the chairs and ranking members
on relevant committees
they have held we've held briefings with
the entire house and senate invited
the house briefing had 124
representatives on including 31
republicans senior white house officials
have briefed bipartisan working groups
in both chambers
including the group of 20 senators and
the problem solvers
caucus and as i noted president looks
forward to welcoming
members uh when they return next week
with that
alex go ahead great thanks uh i have a
couple of questions on the
infrastructure and jobs plan
and uh one item for uh immigration okay
to start the
jobs plan has been receiving opposition
from both the left and the right
um on the right this weekend senator roy
blunt said that it would be an easy
bipartisan win if the bill were more
narrowly focused
so why not reduce the bill down to just
infrastructure and take up planks like
the care workers and the
electric vehicle aspects and then in
addition to that
on the left electric vehicle
infrastructure is hugely important
a 28 tax increase on corporations so is
the white house open to lowering that he
said the highest he would support is 25
well first on the infrastructure uh
question let me say
that uh some republicans who have been
vocal
think investing in water systems and
replacing pipes so americans can have
clean drinking water
is not infrastructure but the president
does some don't think
investing in high-speed rail is
infrastructure the president does
some believe building charging stations
to support america's electric
vehicle future is not infrastructure he
believes it is
build them some don't believe that
america's broadband capacity
uh which is one-third of the american of
america the american people i should say
don't have access to broadband
and improving those lines and expanding
that excess is not infrastructure the
president does
some believe that addressing the issue
of america's supply chains so that we're
never again at the mercy of china or any
other nation
is not investing in infrastructure the
president disagrees
some don't believe that rebuilding
schools so that they're safe and
asbestos-free
is investing in infrastructure the
president disagrees
and finally some don't think that
building a support system to take care
of
elderly parents or kids with
disabilities at home
uh so people can go back into the
workforce some of those
two million women who have left the
workforce during the pandemic
some think that that is not investing in
the infrastructure our workforce of this
country that are the backbone of this
country
the president disagrees but with all
that being said
he is welcomes their ideas hopes he puts
them for
hoops they put them forward and he looks
forward to having conversations with
members of both parties about
how to address uh the long outdated
effort to uh
update our infrastructure is the white
house open to reducing the corporate tax
rate well first the president felt it
was responsible to propose a way to pay
for his proposal
that's exactly what he did he knows some
members think it's too big some think
it's too
too small uh frankly there have been
folks who have come out on both sides
there's package environment fully
expected he knows that some will come
forward with different ways to pay for
this package
and some may have views that it
shouldn't be paid for at all so we fully
expect that from senator manchin and
other members and we expect
uh the question of how to pay for the
package if we should pay for the package
to be part of the discussion moving
forward
is open to that conversation we're open
to hearing ideas and proposals from
members and we
encourage them to put them forward and
then on uh
immigration uh we released a poll
earlier today that suggests that 25
percent of americans only 25 percent
approve of the way that
the president is handling the situation
at the border with respect to
unaccompanied minors so does this poll
suggest that the president needs to
reevaluate his approach
to that issue well if i read the poll
correctly it also had
59 percent of americans believing that
unaccompanied children
should be treated safely and be
protected in that way
and 65 percent supported the
reunification of families
there's no question this is a difficult
challenge and the president believes he
was
elected to address hard problems and his
focus
right now is on expediting processing at
the border
opening up additional facilities
addressing the root causes
and uh restarting programs to
incentivize
kids from applying from when within
their countries so that's his focus
right now
is the issue just a messaging issue then
i mean how do you explain the fact that
americans are not in favor of what the
president is doing at the border i'm not
sure that's an accurate depiction of the
poll
given uh that there was a about one
third of the people who replied didn't
have an opinion at all
so said that they didn't recruit them
fair
but also a three one third said they had
no view
so i think that right now our focus is
not on
uh looking at uh the poll it is on uh
she is doing better at answering these
questions than when we left for break
where i said she's not
well prepared on these questions uh and
hoping that we can
ensure we are protecting these kids we
are i don't know that it really
solves the issue but she's just
answering the questions in a better way
there's not open
the majority of uh people of adults who
come to the border are turned away
uh continuing to implement programs in
the region whether it's
working with them to address root causes
or working with them to restart programs
that can help kids from
apply within country that we feel those
are the ways we can help address what is
no question a challenging issue
go ahead thanks first i want to ask
about the budget
what's the hold up on releasing it we
expect it to be soon
it's not the full budget as you know but
just for clarity purposes it's
a kind of discretionary guidance um but
we hope it to be soon that it will be
soon we expect it to be very soon i
don't have a
timeline on that quite yet every
previous white house has released
at least a budget blueprint or an
outline abbreviated budget by the end of
february so
what's the hold up here why is the delay
what's funny is white house budgets are
political documents that really don't
matter very much
anyway they're like why haven't you
released these completely biased
documents that never become the real
budgets
intransigence from the outgoing
political appointees we had some
cooperation from the career staff but we
didn't have all of the
information that we needed as you all
know we also don't have a
budget director we have not had a budget
director confirmed we have now an acting
budget director which is an important
step forward but again we expect it to
be
uh soon and as soon as we have a
timeline we will make sure you all know
someone asked you a question about major
league baseball uh the league decided to
move its all-star game out of atlanta
that's something that the president said
he supported before does he
then agree with their decision to move
that game out of atlanta within the
voting law
well i i wish i had had this with me on
friday because i got
asked a question and there's just some
help what i thought would be helpful
context and i know you probably don't
have the transcript in front of you
so when the president was asked during
an espn interview last week
he was asked the question last week
major league baseball players
association executive director said that
he would look forward to discussing
moving the all-star game from atlanta in
the wake of georgia's
governor signing into law a bill passed
by the republican-led state legislature
to overhaul how its state elections run
how do you view this possibility of
moving the all-star game out of georgia
and he said quote
i think today's professional athletes
are acting incredibly responsible
i would strongly support them doing that
so he was not
dictating uh for what major league
baseball
uh should do that that they should
dictating they should move the all-star
game
uh that is was their decision they made
that decision and as he
stated earlier he certainly supports
that so he does support the decision to
move again
well he supports them being able to make
the decision
and respond to what the disconnect is
they want biden to have an opinion about
everything the way trump did when it's
just
it's up to the major league baseball to
decide it's not for biden to decide
whether it's good or bad
and that governor desantis in florida
had been
dealing with some sort of some sort of
improper dealings with the supermarket
chain publix
as far as distributing the vaccine so
did those reports
give the white house any pause in
working with governor desantis in the
vaccine program
uh well first let me say that for those
who weren't following this in florida
one of the concerns we've had as we've
watched the data is that
17 percent of florida's population is
african-american
but less than seven percent of
vaccinations have gone to
african-americans
uh in the state uh that's one of the
reasons that we opened four fema sites
in miami tampa jacksonville and orlando
and these sites disproportionately serve
communities of color so
we've been closely watching these data
and these statistics as we would in any
state across the country
and we took these specific actions for
that purpose um
we are not going to hurt the people of
florida uh just because of uh
the the steps or actions of leadership
um
and we will continue to take actions to
ensure that the vaccine is equitably
distributed
go ahead uh just to follow up on the
all-star game uh-oh made the point
that he did not dictate the league move
the all-star game
out of georgia but he likes to say the
words of a president matter
he said he would strongly support if
players in the league wanted to do that
and they did it so does he think
that the pga should move the masters
this week i'm not here to
call for anyone on behalf of the
president or the vice president or
anyone
to take does joe biden want the
designated hitter or does he want
pitchers to bat context of the question
was also around
uh the league meeting to discuss this
exact issue and he answered the question
so then should we believe that if pga
tour players who are arriving in augusta
this
week or today to register for the
tournament if they got together
and decided or talked about not
participating that is something he would
struggle that's what they want to do
i'm sure you will ask me that question
or him this question but
our focus is on doing what we can to add
care making voter voting easier and more
accessible
around the country and that's where our
efforts are going to be from joe biden
supports every league
and its athletes deciding for themselves
what to do
we're moving the all-star game out of
georgia did he consider
the economic impact because the cobb
county
tourism ceo is saying they're going to
lose 100 million dollars
and someone will gain 100 million that
wasn't going to happen okay activity 8
000 hotel rooms did he think about that
before he
said he would strongly support the move
again he was doing an interview
he was given the context as i just read
out to you in full detail of how the
question was asked
he answered the question okay on
immigration 171
000 migrants were caught at the border
and large that's up from 100
000 in february if the trend continues
do you have a sense of how many migrants
the trend never continues
that's like saying look if you look at
today's stock market if this trend
continues the dow will be at 60 000 in a
month well but that's not how it works
we expect that to happen later this week
and for full context
there are numbers that when they release
them will be out like you cited some
version of what you cited
uh but those are reflecting of people
coming and they
we should also be reflecting i hope i'm
encouraging people to do this people who
are turned away
because again uh single adults uh based
on your own reporting and everyone's
reporting
continue to be the vast majority
continue to be turned away
at the border i don't have any
predictions about numbers that will come
we're obviously taking steps as i uh
addressed in
a response if this trend continues do
you know what the dow will look like in
a month programs that people can utilize
to apply it from
in country uh send a clear message the
border is not open and that we're
turning away
the majority of adults when they come to
the border there is a
separate report that speaking about the
adults there are a
thousand got aways mostly in arizona
people who
are seen detected but they are not
chased because authorities are so busy
processing the families the washington
post is reporting that some of these
people are carrying
drugs has the administration maybe
reached
mexico to try to stop the flow of drugs
or
help stop the flow of drugs into
american communities
that's such a lightweight dramatic
conversations uh certainly through the
state department and other entities
within the government
i'm happy to check on that specific
reporting i had not seen that report
since before i came out here
great um go ahead kelly in clarifying
today are you trying to roll back what
the president said
about the all-star game articulate
clearly to everyone
what uh what he said and what the
context of his remarks were
the question that was asked and the full
scope of his answer
and i think it's been shorthanded to no
one's fault because it was it's been
repeated a bit without the full context
and mitch mcconnell says uh that we are
witnessing a coordinated campaign by
powerful and wealthy people
to mislead uh and to use the bully uh
pulpit
about this law she must be talking about
trump's list of 12 companies to boycott
trying to influence corporations or
organizations to take action
on state level decisions like this we've
conveyed it and i'm happy to answer your
question directly we've not uh
not asked corporations to take specific
actions that's not
our focus here our focus is on and
continuing to convey that it's important
that voting is easier
not harder that when there are laws in
place that make it harder we certainly
express an opposition to those laws
a couple of foreign policy questions
it's now april 5th
the afghanistan decision is due
soon troops and their families are
interested to know
what the president's decision will be
what more does he need before he can
make or announce this decision
well as the president has said before
it will be tough to meet the may 1st
deadline for
full withdrawal for logistical reasons
we are continuing he's continuing to
consult internally with his national
security
team and advisors and of course also
with our partners and allies
and uh you know he has not he's been
working on these issues foreign policy
issues national security issues for
several decades now and of course wants
to take the time to make the right
decision
so our expectation should be that it
will go beyond may first
with the top well yeah portion of your
house you set the expectation it will be
tough for a full withdrawal for
logistical reasons by that timeline and
that certainly has
also something that we've conveyed
clearly to our partners as well
but in terms of uh what's next you know
he just wants to take the time to make
a decision what's the president's level
of concern about what's happening in
jordan
long a an important country an ally and
a buffer against some of the
hotter events in that part of the world
uh is this
something where he would have any direct
interaction
at this point i would expect it would be
through the state department and
wouldn't expect that
we're of course closely following the
reports out of jordan we've been
in touch as an administration with
jordanian officials
king abdullah is a key partner of the
united states he has our full support
go ahead yeah so on ukraine we talked
about this on friday but
the state department has now asked
russia to explain these provocations
by the way we'll hear the answer blood
and oil about mohammed bin salman i read
the book over the vacation
highly highly recommend it any calls
with president putin to predict at this
point in time
last week it was read out that national
that our secretary of state
had a conversation with his counterpart
also the secretary of defense had a
conversation with his
counterpart we remain concerned by the
recent
escalations of russian aggressive
russian aggression and
provocative actions in eastern ukraine
that's something we're watching closely
of course
uh we're aware of their uh the ukrainian
military reports concerning russian
troop movements on ukraine's
border uh but at this point uh we've
been in touch at the secretary of state
and
secretary of defense uh level uh which
is pretty high as we all know uh but i
don't have any
calls from the president to predict for
you and just one more uh uh
i of course spoke with the with the
president of ukraine on on friday as
well so that's right
about this specific issue yeah so on the
uh on the front on the tax front um i
understand that you're um you know not
willing to sort of
close in on a specific number that you
might agree with joe with
john engine but have you done a detailed
analysis of what the delta would be
say if you agreed to 25 how much less
income revenue would that distribute are
you doing that kind of a detailed
analysis and preparation for these
negotiations
well i mean first i think it's important
to remind people that the corporate tax
rate we're proposing
is lower than it was in 2017. in fact
it's lower than it was from world war
ii until 20. there's actually a more
important reminder most businesses don't
pay the corporate tax rate because
they're passed through entities
uh since anyone in this room was alive i
think or around that amount of time
uh so uh that's our proposal of course
what the president proposed raising it
to 28 percent
and and combined with the other tax
proposals would pay for the totality of
the package that's
why he felt it was a responsible
proposal to make
um sorry this person was throwing me off
outside for a second but everything's
fine
um so what uh he felt it was responsible
with me
there will be different ideas for pay
fors right there will be different ideas
for tax proposals
that will all need to be weighed by a
range of questions inclu with congress
and with leaders in congress
and outspoken members in congress about
whether it should be paid for
over what period of time how much should
be paid for what the options are for
paying for it
there's some that are proposing as you
all know salt deductions in other
areas that are not revenue raisers so
this will be all a part of the
discussion and
absolutely our economic team and number
data crunchers will be crunching
numbers as we proceed but uh we're kind
of in the early stages of these
discussions at this point in time
quickly on omb you mentioned that you
don't have a budget director yet when do
you anticipate that the president will
nominate someone to replace nira tandon
and then i have one more quick
international one sure and i should
have convey which i did but i will
reiterate we of course have an acting
omb
director shilon young who is beloved by
capitol hill as you all know um and so
she is of course
playing a very important role but we
didn't have one for some period of time
because she was only recently
confirmed as the deputy and now the
acting i don't have a personal update
for you in terms of the timeline for
nominating a formerly nominating a
replacement on omb
a lot of people have said that they
think shalonda young should just get the
job i mean that she should be nominated
for the number one job
can you say anything more on that i
would just say the president thinks so
highly of her that he has nominated her
to serve as the deputy director of omb
which is also an enormous job but i've
been here long enough not to make
predictions of
where he will land on a personnel
announcement international front so the
imf and the world bank are meeting this
week this is a big deal internationally
one of the issues that has come up is is
a sort of a need to expand
the debt relief initiatives to beyond
countries that are just the poorest
countries and there are
significant numbers of countries that
are you know middle-income countries
is this something that the president is
is willing to take on and is this a
message that he wants his
officials to send during these important
meetings
well there's no question that the kovit
19 pandemic has deepened global economic
inequality
and as has already been announced by the
treasury department
we are working the u.s the united states
is working with imf management
other members toward a 650 billion
dollar general allocation
to imf member countries it's part of a
package of broader international efforts
to support the global recovery
also includes robust support for the imf
multilateral development banks
debt relief in some cases all alongside
countries
taking necessary reform steps so we're
working closely with the imf
and other member countries uh given we
are all working through uh
the impact of a global pandemic you
don't want to say anything about
expanding the universe of countries that
are going to get help
because right now it's limited to just
the countries yeah
i i would point you to the treasury
department for more specifics beyond
that
uh go ahead and so one thing quickly and
then
i have something else is there any
update on when
uh you or the president will release his
latest medical records or any update on
his plans to
visit his medical provider i don't have
an update i'm happy to check with our
team and see if there's one we can
provide you all
uh soon in short order
anything more precise than soon i i'll
have to check with the team and
before i give you a specific timeline of
when we'll have that available
and then back on the mlb question
given that as you say the president
supports the ability to make this
decision
does he also support other organizations
or businesses
making similar moves supports them
having the ability
boycotting other events in other states
should they pass similar laws i'm
thinking here of arizona and others that
may be considering similar voting
restriction laws
that's not something we're calling for
from the white house our focus
is on working with congress to put in
place
voting rights legislation working with
leaders uh
in uh who like stacey abrams and others
who are advocating for
more expanded laws uh and more expanded
information
out to people to make it easier to vote
so those are really that's really where
our efforts are focused although
i mean some of this may be moving at a
faster pace
in these states then you're going to be
able to get
a an omnibus national voting rights law
passed
so there will be moments of inflection
moments here between now and then
where other organizations would be
looking at making the same kinds of
decisions that mlb made
does the president think they should be
able to make those decisions
and to pull out as well i mean broadly
speaking of course the president
and i believe private sector entities
are going to make decisions and
that's their uh their role to do so uh
whatever
like hasn't the position of the right
been that companies should do whatever
they want
and now that's biden's position and
they're like whoa whoa whoa what's
biden's position now
voting rights legislation continuing to
voice and advocate for the need to make
it
uh easier and not harder to vote that's
where he will be spending his time and
effort and as will we in the white house
and lastly on iran with the indirect
talks beginning tomorrow
i mean here it is the first week of
april this is a
foreign policy priority of the
presidents through
throughout the campaign really one of
the very few
specific things he said he wanted to do
is he disappointed that it has taken
this long to get to what isn't even a
face-to-face negotiation
and does he think that there is still
time to pull a deal together before
iranian elections
uh in june well um he knows
from living through it as do you from
covering it for many years that
uh diplomacy can take time and sometimes
it is not at the pace that
everyone would prefer and we certainly
have experience as does he
from having been in the obama biden
administration of the time it took to
work through a diplomatic
process i don't have a prediction to
make in terms of how long it will take
you're right that of course what is
happening in all seriousness guys
was the date of biden's joint address to
the house and senate announced while i
was on break i haven't heard it it's
supposed to be this month as far as i
know
diplomacy and that remains our first
objective remain
that the us will not drop any sanctions
until iran
returns to full compliance well his
position hasn't changed on how he's
approaching or we should approach the
negotiations and
we certainly expect that the primary
issues that will be discussed over the
course of the coming days
are the nuclear steps that iran would
need to take in order to return to
compliance
with the terms of the jcpoa and the
sanctions relief steps that you the
united states would need to take
in order to return to compliance as well
but we're just at the beginning
of the talks and uh we don't anticipate
presently
that there will be direct talks between
the united states and iran through this
process though we remain
certainly open to that prospect go ahead
i'll come back to you caitlin i'm sorry
go ahead um you mentioned last week on
infrastructure
that you'd like to see progress on the
bill by memorial day
i wonder if you can just define progress
what do you want to see happen by
memorial day
i don't think i'm going to define
progress more than you know we hope
members will be proposing ideas we hope
that there will be
constructive discussions uh we hope that
they'll be committees meeting
but we'll leave it to hat hill
leadership to define
what progress looks like is this back on
senator blunt's proposal about a smaller
package
is it out of the question for the white
house to split up the infrastructure
package or is that something that fresno
would be
willing to do well we certainly expected
and it has played out that some will
believe that the package we proposed is
too small
some will believe it's too big and we're
happy to have discussions
with members who have both points of
view but at the end of the day the
package that the president proposed
makes a historic investment in our
nation's infrastructure
rebuilds our economy uh helps create 19
million jobs
and you know we're hopeful that others
will come forward with ideas that are as
bold and innovative and will help do the
same
uh type of work for american workers in
our economy and then also just
one more um on the american families
plan i think you said that you expected
that
biden to talk about that um sometime at
the end of april
uh i just wonder if you can give a
specific timeline on that
and would the strategy there be to try
to pass at the same time as
infrastructure
or would you wait until after an
infrastructure package gets across the
finish line we're not gonna i'm not
gonna be able to outline the legislative
strategy for a package we haven't
proposed yet but i
i said at the time in the coming weeks
but i don't have anything more specific
than that at this point in time
caitlyn just to follow on jordan the
budget
are we not going to get it until there's
a budget director in place
no no i didn't mean to convey that
message he was asking
what the impact what the delay was
caused by and and largely it was caused
by
intransigence in part during the
transition uh but also we didn't have a
confirmed budget director for
a period of time uh so that is a factor
too so that was answering that part of
his question
get the budget before there's actually a
budget well there'll be a couple
different components
and these terms are so um washington but
here we are
so there's the discretionary guidance
which would be the first piece of this
which
would be short not a very long document
a skinny budget uh and a longer budget
so there's
a short long and skinny budget and
various sized packages
guys can't why is isn't it obvious what
they're talking about they are open to
alternative proposals from other
lawmakers democrats and republicans
but roy blunt has put one forward it's
600 billion dollars it's more
traditional definition
of infrastructure so is the white house
open to anything that he has laid out in
this proposal
or that he says he's pitched directly to
the white house well i think what i was
conveying is that
it's time for people to be bolder and
more forward-looking about what
infrastructure looks like
infrastructure is not just the roads we
get a horse and buggy across
infrastructure is about broadband it's
about replacing lead pipes so people
have
water it's about rebuilding our schools
and so of course we're happy to hear
proposals but uh you know i think this
the definition of infrastructure we have
a disagreement about
so what is the white house's definition
of infrastructure exactly
well i think it's what i went through
earlier when alex
asked the question which is clearly
a number of the items i just talked
about it is rebuilding schools it is
rebuilding our nation's waterways it is
ensuring that we can rebuild
pipes so that we don't have kids with
lead in their drinking water
it is rebuilding the backbone and the
infrastructure of our workforce
because there are two million women who
are out of the workforce who
yeah this was answered already could
help them with caregiving will be able
to rejoin
so there are a number of components that
that i outlined earlier but uh
that we believe define how we can invest
in an innovative forward-looking way in
our economy
in our workers create jobs and that's
the proposal
we put forward and we look forward to
having discussions about so one thing
that senator blunt proposed was paying
for it and user fees and other revenue
streams that's not raising the corporate
tax rate and in this proposal that we
have from the president
eight years of spending 15 years of
taxes so what happens what is his
defense to lawmakers who ask
what happens when he's not president and
the congress is different and if they
repealed
those tax changes well then then i hope
you'd be asking
um whoever's standing right here who
might be a republican if they ruled them
back
that exact question at the time but our
view is that the corporate tax rate
which again is uh what we were proposing
it be at a rate that is
still lower than it was in 2017 and
lower than it was from between world war
ii
and 2017. our view is that corporations
can pay more not that it should be on
the backs of
consumers and the american people
through user fees which is exactly what
is
the question i would love to hear is
given that so many corporations pay no
taxes regardless of what the rate is
what is actually going to be done about
that rather than
a theatrical fight about 21 27 or 28.
in what would have amounted to 15
million one-shot doses which is a lot
for what we're trying to do
so what was the president's reaction to
that
to the to the news well i would first
say that
so the fact that we're not getting 15
million doses right now that
could have been made for american people
it's not exactly what happened because
we are still on track to have the number
of doses we need
to vaccinate all adult americans by the
end of may
this was not even a facility that was
approved by the fda
so we were not betting on these doses we
were betting on doses coming from
moderna pfizer and also johnson johnson
has assured us that we will be getting
the 24 million yeah also like
obviously the biden administration has
no oversight over that factory they made
a mistake they tainted 15 million doses
but it's what it has nothing to do with
biden
to take steps over the weekend to ensure
that johnson johnson is the only
uh drug that is being produced at the
site given that the issue as you well
know caitlin was about
the cross-contamination of uh
astrazeneca and johnson johnson so there
were still take
steps taken to address this moving
forward but we were not
betting on these to vaccinate the
american public
the adult americans that we have assured
people we will have enough doses by
the end of may we remain we continue to
believe we will
but is he worried that something like
this happening can
affect vaccine hesitancy that we're
already seeing in the united states
well we haven't seen that to date but
this is why the fda approval process is
in place
in many ways it was the process working
because the fda had not approved this
site
there were steps taken to address what
some of the issues were
and we also have a range of contingency
plans you know when when
we all talk and hear about why did we
order so many doses why are we at the
point where we are sharing doses with
every country around the world
part of it is because we need to plan
for things coming up things like this
come up
uh this is obviously as you noted a big
number of doses but there are we have to
plan for a range of
contingencies that's exactly this is one
of them yeah it's uh one of the many
reasons that we're going to still be in
a place where we have enough vaccines
for
adult americans by the end of may go
ahead
what is the structure does the president
support the idea of a possible second
reconciliation if the white house
proposal does not receive
any republican support well we believe
with 80 percent of the public supporting
infrastructure investment with even
proposals coming forward
supporting components of the package
that if we start on areas where we agree
we can move forward with bipartisan
support and any more background you can
provide on which lawmakers specifically
republicans
the white house is reaching out to and
inviting to
to the white house for meetings not yet
i'm i'm sure when we have a meeting set
and we have the members all confirmed
we'll share
the names with you why share a list now
when someone might not show up and then
they're like you said uh you said romney
was going and he didn't go did you lie
shots or ramp up in production of
booster shots or research and
development
for new vaccine to deal with the many
variants
sure well one of the issues that we've
been focused on is
again ensuring that we have flexibility
as it relates to vaccine
doses that we have ordered that could
include now the fda is still going
through the pot
the process of approval for booster
shots and determining of course what's
needed and when we would we would leave
it to them and the cdc of course
to make that determination an
announcement but we do have flexibility
in the doses we've purchased
moving forward should that be a need
just to clarify that point is operation
work speed still in effect
was it ever that to address
oh that's that's rich additional vaccine
well companies are still are producing
uh booster shots and options they're
being uh
you know they're being reviewed by the
fda so i'm not sure
that's just a process that's ongoing
with companies in hhs
go go ahead oh sorry let me let me just
get around to everybody and they'll come
back go ahead
yeah uh chief of staff ron clayne said
last week that president biden has asked
the u.s department of education to
prepare a memo
on the president's legal authority to
cancel student debt
uh what exactly has the white house
asked for here
and in the past uh president biden said
he would be prepared to write off ten
thousand dollars in debt
but not fifty thousand like some
liberals and democrats
um have asked for is biden rethinking
his position
and is he reconsidering his position on
the idea of canceling
uh debt of students who attended more
expensive private schools
well first he continues to look
look forward to he'd welcome a bill
signed by or passed by congress i should
say
to cancel ten thousand dollars jen does
does the president support a 24-hour
cancellation policy for dentistry
appointments or does he think that if
you're sick you shouldn't be charged
was referring to is the fact that
there's an ongoing review it's both a
policy review
and a legal review so department of
education and department of justice to
look at what the options are
and what authority could be recommended
to the president so that was the process
he was referring to
if he's asking what options are
available does that mean
whether he can do it to 50 000 and does
that mean that it's therefore open as a
possibility for the white house
yeah it's his pal his position hasn't
changed there's a review to
take a look at uh at um what is possible
with executive authority well he has
indicated he doesn't think that's a good
proposal
during the town hall back in february he
very much suddenly
you know was outspoken against the 50
000
threshold so where does he stand on that
at this point and again
after that point in time ron clayne and
others have spoken with
a range of leaders in congress and we've
said many times from this podium that
there is an ongoing review
of what the options are that are
possible under executive authority
there's also a policy review as would be
expected at the same time
we haven't ruled out options but that
review is ongoing there isn't a
conclusion of it
let me just go ahead thanks um i have an
infrastructure and a baseball question
here oh
hey um so last week the white house put
out a fact sheet about the
infrastructure plan
that cited the texas power outage excuse
me as evidence of the urgent need to
modernize
the nation's electric grid which kind of
leaves the implication that
texas will get funding to upgrade its
grid but i haven't seen that
specifically so
can you offer assurance that there
actually would be money in this
for texas to modernize upgrade
weatherize it's great
this is believe it or not oh you will
believe it of course a very common
question from a lot of reporters and
media outlets across the country
um we will we will have some state fact
sheets i expect soon that kind of break
down some of the specifics there are
pieces like broadband access and other
things
but there'll be a competitive bidding
process once the bill
is signed into law and we'll probably
won't yeah private industry will be
doing the actual work and getting lots
of great
contracts i think that's a really um
vague part of the plan what do you mean
by a competitive bidding process
is this like how do the top bridges or
power grids get chosen i mean is it is
it a form
do you envision a formula based on state
population
or is a federal department deciding
which is a more critical
project than another it's we're not
quite there yet we just proposed this a
couple of days ago
uh a competitive bidding process which i
think most americans would support
would mean that uh states entities have
to apply for
it's like you know these are their
government requests for proposals like
this stuff this is not
i mean in a sense maybe it's been so
long like trump just handed contracts
out to his friends so maybe it's
actually been a long time and they don't
remember how this stuff works
we'll all be advocating for different
projects we certainly expect that
but we're in the early stages of the
process and so these congressional
meetings these are really weird putting
specific projects on a list
no okay my baseball question is today's
home opener for the texas rangers is the
first
major league sports event since the
pandemic started
that excuse me that allows an open a
full a full house
the president called that a mistake last
week has he
spoken to other team owners to try to
deter them and hold off from having full
house events
i don't have any calls from the
president to baseball team owners
to to read out i would say that the
president continues to reiterate the
need to follow public health guidelines
there are restrictions as you all know
recommended including unmasking
social distancing which of course
applies to having a full stadium
imagine biden calling like whichever
steinbrenner is now running the yankees
and being like
no full crowd and no sausage and peppers
in the country
that's something we're closely watching
and just a reminder of how important it
is to be vigilant
very last question are any federal
assets going to be used to track
whether this event actually does lead to
a spike i would send that question to
the cdc
uh go ahead thank you very much jen i
have a question about
immigration president biden has spoken
publicly about how during the
obama administration he worked with
central american countries and
i just talked about how he was helped
negotiate getting 700 million dollars in
aid to
help those countries prevent the flow of
migrants coming north
what lessons did the president learn
from that experience that he's applying
to
dealing with the crisis now well i think
one of the reasons the president asked
and tell me if this is answering a
question but
one of the reasons the president asked
his vice president to play a similar
role that he played
is because he recognizes that unless we
address the root causes in these
countries
unless we disincentivize young people
families leaving these countries we
improve the economic conditions
we create spaces for them to be in these
countries that
avoids the corruption that is in place
in many of the governments
we will continue to go through cycle
after cycle some of these programs and
obviously the funding was not advanced
during the last administration
and some of the programs were reversed
so
you know his experience impacts him and
affects him because he knows
we need to address the current
challenges we're having at the border
those are immediate but in order to
address it longer term
we need to address the root causes in
the countries is his expectation
snapping back the funding that was cut
during the
trump administration or are there
additional things that he's expecting to
see
uh implement in the region well he's
proposed four billion dollars in funding
in his immigration proposal
so he certainly believes that we need
more it's not just reinstituting
programs
we also need more and we need to build
from there and he expects to
of course be briefed by our envoy who's
going to be back and forth in the region
others who will be involved and of
course the vice president who will be
very closely involved in these
conversations as well what can we expect
on
on climate when can we expect to see the
u.s commitments
under the paris agreement that the u.s
announced it would re-enter on february
4. when when can the public see
what those u.s commitments are going to
look like when well i expect when we
have our climate summit in a couple of
weeks there'll be an update and we'll
discuss more on a big national stage
with a bully pulpit um
what where we are going from here where
we are where we're going from here and
of course gina mccarthy and other
members of our climate team uh
former secretary john kerry are hard at
work on
uh putting together plans and working to
implement go ahead
thank you jen two questions uh first
in response to kelly's question earlier
he reiterated the us's strong support
for jordan and for king abdullah as a
strong ally
now the reports about the arrest of the
deposed crown prince
and 20 others are now 24 hours
old has the president made any calls to
the king and amman
reiterating that support i don't have
any calls to read out what i tried to
convey to kelly was that those calls or
those engagements would likely happen
out of the state department at this
point in time
all right the other thing on the
infrastructure package there
is a private memo that's being
circulated in the business community
and to some republican senators that
said that the
2.25 trillion dollar price tag
is 1 trillion off and that there's many
things in there that were
omitted in the initial discussion of the
bill notably
the um 300 billion dollar
energy tax credit the 100 billion
dollars for the green bank
and that these things would add one
trillion dollars to it
this is being circulated on the hill do
you have any response to the charge that
the president
lowballed the price tag on the
infrastructure bill sounds mysterious
the memo the secret memo
uh is it are you saying just so i
understand your question are you saying
there are things the president didn't
put in his proposal people think he's
going to add to his proposal
no there's things there that somebody
went through it or is claiming to have
gone through it and added it up
and came up with one trillion more than
the president
listed as the price tag so it is
actually 3.25 trillion
as opposed to we laid out very
specifically
each component of the package and how
much we're proposing so
i would encourage you all to get your
calculators out and
charge that up and see how it compares
to the to the secret memo
oh wait go ahead in the back and then we
can come back around to the front go
ahead
the cc updated the cover
cover related travel guidance last
friday
is the administration considering losing
some international travel restrictions
i don't have anything to predict on that
front obviously that would be done by
our health and medical experts
um yes there's probably yeah for any uh
timeline on the guidelines
will you accept other vaccines that are
approved by other countries that's
not appropriate fda yet will we accept
them here in the united states yeah as
like
um qualified uh vaccine good question
uh i may not be totally understanding
your question we we have we are
we have ordered supply no wrong question
he's not he's not answering the request
by the fda she's saying that's what
we're focused on if you allow vaccinated
people in
do you allow them in if they're
vaccinated with sputnik for example
vaccines that are fda approved go ahead
you've been very patient thanks uh
it's not the question that's that's
disappointing because she asked a very
good question
and jen didn't understand it and she
just moved on sort of taking over that
facility
wholesale what does that mean for the
astrozetica vaccine
and will it affect their ability to
manufacture here in the united states
or that production domestically now
shrink
well um first we're working with
astrazeneca to immediately immediately
identify other facilities to continue
their domestic
manufacture of astrazeneca drug
substance and several options are under
consideration
as you know it hasn't been approved as
rzeneka through the fda
yet johnson johnson has uh hence the
importance of johnson and johnson
uh production uh continuing to uh be
expedited
thanks sure go ahead so a small question
just trying to
make certain i understand uh where you
are with taxation on
the individual level on friday in the
president's remarks in the state dining
room
he said uh it won't raise a penny tax on
a family making less than 400
000 a year last week there were some
questions about this you also included
individuals
so is it families drink filers please
don't say both
threshold it is he will not raise taxes
on any individual or family member
makes sense ten thousand dollars a year
we expect there'll be more specifics on
uh what he's proposing some of the
things that he's talked about on the
campaign individual
or as it relates to individuals as we
get closer to the rollout of the uh
families plan
go ahead i guess it could be 400
personal and 800k household right that's
the only way that that statement could
make sense
decide how to reopen uh the united
teachers of
los angeles union uh their members are
asking for free child
care for their own kids for the teachers
kids
to go back does the white house think
that that is something that they should
get
i would point you to the state of
california and the local school
districts to have those discussions
and then just one more quick one on
georgia to put a
bow on it um is the president going to
change the way that he talks about
the new georgia voting law because
in that interview that he referenced he
said the law would end voting at five
o'clock when working people are just
getting up and he said it would end
voting hours early so working people
can't cast
their vote after their shift is over but
the washington post
gave that claim four pinocchios because
that part of the law gives counties the
option to
extend voting hours and so i'm just
curious
if the president is going to change the
way that he's talking well
fundamentally the president doesn't
believe it should be made harder to vote
he believes it should be easier and this
bill makes it harder to request and
return an absentee ballot
it collapses the length of georgia's
runoff election making it harder for
large jurisdictions to operate
voting it imposes rigid new restrictions
on local officials ability to set
polling hours to suit the needs of
voters in their county
those are all pieces of the bill so his
view
is that we need to make it easier and
not harder to vote and that will
continue to be what he advocates for
but the thing he said has been
determined by
election law experts to be not true
so i'm just curious if he's going to
stop saying well again
i think we can uh the fact checkers will
also tell you
that uh this bill does not make it
easier for people across
the state of georgia to vote sort of
weak on this one has concerns
uh go ahead semiconductors um
we've got this april 12 meeting up with
uh coming up with senior
uh officials but also from industry can
you give us
a list of companies that will be
participating in that
and then there was a report out on
japanese
media saying that the president and the
japanese prime minister
were working toward an agreement on
supply chain
um shoring up the supply chain for
semiconductors
can you say anything more about what you
whether there is some kind of agreement
in the works
and what you're expecting to come out of
both of those meetings
uh well first i expect when we get
closer to the meeting we will have and
we have a confirmed list of participants
we will share the list of
companies and participants with you but
probably not until we get much closer to
that actual
meeting as it relates to japan as we've
made clear the u.s japan alliance is a
cornerstone of
peace security and prosperity in the
region
and that is one of the reasons why we're
working to deepen our close
coordination across a variety of areas
including supply chains as secretary of
state lincoln
discussed with his counterpart last
month but in terms of specifics of those
discussions and what's possible in the
future
i just don't have anything to preview
for you at this point in time sorry can
i just do one quick call
peter yeah but the president does
acknowledge that the new law
doesn't change election day voting hours
right
well look katelyn it also doesn't expand
them
uh for early voting it makes early
voting shorter
so there are a lot of components of the
legislation he is concerned about and
that's what he was expressing right
just he does acknowledge that because
his comments have been confusing
about closing it at 5 pm that's correct
so he does acknowledge that it doesn't i
think what's important is to report on
all the components that make it more
difficult to vote in the package in the
legislation
all right so we have a special guest i
will say that we
oh my god that this is one of the events
where people get to take their children
family members friends too and it's not
quite the same we'll do a big one next
year but we still wanted to have a
visitor
and some special commemorative easter
eggs for all of you from
um from the president and the first one
the hell
not today but we'll invite the bunny
back for a future briefing as always
but the bunny's wearing a mask where you
we take no
use every opportunity is this the same
bunny
uh i it does not look similar but
we'll have to fact check that out did
you guys hear that is this the same
bunny suit that sean spicer wore
are we giving those out yes we're gonna
see this is cringe
all right get the bunny he's gonna be
the bunny's helper
he will be delivering uh eggs and make
sure each of you get one
and some chocolates to take home to your
loved ones
thank you everyone thank you
so there is another easter well that is
an easter press briefing in the books
some funny super chats i want to read
what is the presidential
opinion of major league baseball fans
attempting to circumvent the mass
guidelines by double fisting cold
beers at ball games very good question
um do they think biden micromanages the
entire government they sort of seem to
think so welcome back missed you hope
you had fun in florida i was in aruba
not florida
david i'm hearing that the immorality
and possible illegality of the discount
code may lead to a revocation of the
many awards given to the world famous
award-winning
bonus show are you concerned yes i've
retained counsel
over that um
david says david i just renewed my
membership with the better 21
incredibly massive coupon code is your
accountant aware of this
yeah he's trying to stop it he's trying
to
trying to stop it thanks to david
ricciardi for signing up on my website
as well as
joe kau jakowski also thanks to putz
and splash mock and a whole bunch of
other people
we are back and better than ever
new clips starting in 90 minutes
uh podcast coming out
in an hour my full vacation story
including deep nose
swab on today's bonus show
don't miss any of it and i'll see
everybody tomorrow